yesterday i was going to manga colombia
to meet jennifer
no anticipation on sleeping together
whatsoever and within 24 hours we are
now hiking up next to each other
thank you
i feel
like a virgin
rediscovering like
whoa like we had this fire i if i could
put like
a fire emoji right now it would be here
i mean that that's just all i can say
it's it's complete fire
i'm just so so grateful like waking up
next to you and
having these experiences with you
that's just the best way of like waking
up next to each other i love it i really
feel like we have been together for much
more time right it's crazy it's just oh
wait i think that's the breakfast yeah
i feel
very happy because all of my fear just
went off
with jesse which was like we couldn't
connect sexually but no he's super
like tossing and and curling and just
giving love and it's it's yeah it's
wonderful
oh my god i love that they're croissants
they're so cute it looks like shrimp
[Laughter]
so i woke up this morning and i realized
we're not even 24 hours in and look at
what we're doing and like how we feel
and
wow you know i i never had like you know
just like you such an experience where
it was just like i was energized i was
awake again
you just like you know started that fire
i mean
i was thinking the whole like hotel room
was going to be like on fire it was
beautiful
yeah
he's very strong and like dominant like
me we are both dominant
like and we get like to change
sometimes he gets dominant sometimes i'm
determined
yeah it was it was it was yeah i think
it was yeah
[Music]
one of the best
[Music]
you